sir alec
throwing the slab
come after these diamondback hitters
with a an arsenal of sinker change up
four seamer slider and curve ball
four and three now with the four
six four eras been significantly better
as a starter
than a reliever
that's center brian can't get it and
drops in
escobar digging for second
and he is in there eduardo with a double
starting pitcher for the diamondbacks
there he is meryl kelly it's brought to
you by budweiser he's brought to you by
windows here this buds
for you he like alec not an overpowering
guy but knows how to pitch four seamer
sinker curve change
and cutter six and seven with a 446. he
was dynamite against the cubs
in the desert on sunday
drive base hit out into center field
van meter was shifted and he was there
but he just wasn't tall enough
[Applause]
rizzo got a sinker middle middle popped
it up
peralta
runs it down once again confusion out
there might have gotten up into that
wind which is blowing out in center
but they track it down and we're through
one no score
3-1
hit on the ground to third backhanded
wisdom firing on the move pick
wisdom on one end rizzo on the other and
mills loves it really nice play and nick
ahmed the gold glover himself
somewhere in the deep recesses of his
mind he appreciates it too just maybe
not right this second
2-0 in the air center field going back
is smith can't get it rolls all the way
to the fence
alec mills with a double how about that
sir alec
david smith tracking this ball like he
like he had a bead on it
but clearly did not the line drive off
the bat of alec mills continued to
my carry base hit right field
calhoun picking up the stop mills at
third and ortega
with a base hit puts runners at the
corners
[Applause]
on the ground to third escobar they get
one there return to first and they get
two run comes in and the cubs lead it
mills scores
little dribbler out front of the plate
contreras pounces on it
and then hits escobar oh boy
that's safe at first
he's calling him out he's telling him
about for running in the lane
[Music]
he's torn between arguing with the
umpire and checking in on escobar
contreras through that ball
as the kids like to say with all his
might
[Music]
this the spot was far enough out in
front of home play where wilson had a
good enough angle to make this truck
throws a little bit offline and you'll
see escobar he's
working his way back man that's a tough
call we see this all the time
he's inside the lane here but he moves
back towards the base
he gets drilled
i wonder how hard that throw was and if
escobar is going to stay in the
now
game
now this play's over starting in the
morning we're not okay where was i
not like i was running
in the lane
i think there has to be more
a judgment call on that play
in the air right field pretty well
struck calhoun
and that one is gone
the opposite way
and he changed his shoes from the first
at bat
the cubs get the homer and it's now 2-0
all right so wilson contreras mentioned
first time up next time up we go gold
shoes we got white shoes gold shoes that
got hit by a pitch white shoes he hit a
home run
chance for varshall maybe to cash in
right here
it's this one in the air to center
ortega look it up that's gone dalton
varshall
ties the ball game
three consecutive games with a home run
and it's 2-2
merrell kelly bidding for extra bases
it's in the ivy and after we watch alec
mills double the center in the third
merrill kelly a two out double the left
in the fifth drupal cabrera off the
injured list today in the on deck circle
15 pitches only five strikes for
chaffing
and there's another base hit for bar
show and they are gonna wait pavement
smith the throw from bryant is cut off
d-backs have the lead and dalton far
show has done it again
he's knocked in all six d-backs runs in
this series
right-hander tepera warming up in their
bullpens two and two on cabrera
punches that one the other way it's
headed to the corner and it gets down
ahmed will score varshall flying to the
third here he comes
as dromo cabrera makes it five to two
welcome back
cabrera is in third
escobar in second
[Music]
hayward sends one out to center haven
smith near the ivy and he's got it
into the ivy out there
there's a lot of regular center fielders
that don't make this play i mean it
looks nice and the nature of it all but
those are leaves over a brick wall
going over there one more time
hayward backing up heads off the army
and rolls away
cabrera on that hammy will stop at
second two at bats and two doubles
welcome back as drooble
both to the opposite field look like
hayward lost that ball at one point
there toward the end
which is the pitcher spot they'll bat
andrew young
chance for the smasher against the lefty
he gets it up in the air to hayward
andrew young there it goes the smasher
is back in town
and it's 7-2
that's his sixth of the year andrew
young
center field here comes ortega that
drops in front
and it's a basin for escobar there are
storms
forecasted in the area
folks the folks are starting to head out
of the ballpark
see if they can turn this they get one
and they get two due to lightning in the
area for your safety please leave the
area and seek shelter immediately
so be careful
we'll be back with baseball hopefully
sometime soon but right now
with a weather delay rain and lightning
in the area welcome back we are excited
and everybody in the dugout is you hear
that music you know what's happening
and it's over evacs get the win 7-3